Pilot: How's it going?
Denis: Good
Pilot: Just fill in from the back foward if you would please.
Denis: No problem
Hello
oof
So here this is DSL (Dark Sector Lab)
current home of BICEP3
and this is the SPT 10-meter South Pole telescope
actually observing.
So today is actually really beautiful day
we're walking back towards the station
here's the tour of the horizon over
there
the ceremonial South Pole little bit
further of their the actual South Pole
the station, kirat a very famous
South Pole marker, a satellite dish over
there
the skiway over here going towards the
Dark Sector, the ice cube laboratory, SPT
South Pole telescope 10-meter telescope
BICEP, DSL there, maypo
and nothingness.
Pretty cool
Go take a look at the window on the lee
side of the station you'll see how windy
it is
pretty low visibility there's snow being
blown in the air has turned into a
little bit worse than it was yesterday
and the day before and it turns out
South Pole has a running scroll of a
bunch of useful information including
the weather the South pole so you can
just log onto the local intranet which
you can actually access and take a look
at page like this although it's pretty
cold minus 30 it is quite windy 23 knots
that's a little over 40 kilometers an
hour that's quite windy for the South
Pole so it's a little bit like blizzard
conditions in addition to the weather
you have a list of the flights
these are the flights that actually
should have arrived today, but because of
weather they were cancelled as well as
the satellite passes this is the time
and the three satellites that we
communicate with right now we should be
able to use goes but because it's an
orange it actually just means that it's,
useless,
we actually can't get to the internet
from the outside world.
[Inaudible sounds]
If you're like me and fascinated by Antarctica and all things scientific you
might want to learn even more at the
great courses plus who supported this
video they have a whole course filled
with films about pole exploration from
the science of Antarctica, photography at
the poles, and even life among penguins.
You could watch about ten and a half
hours of amazing videos about Antarctica
right now or thousands of hours on
pretty much anything else you can think
of all presented by real experts in the
field.
"No more warm tropical climates with
jungles and swamps the last 35 million years have been all about ice"
No matter what you're into the great
courses plus is gonna have you covered
and at the moment they're giving you a
month-long free trial to all the videos
all their courses so why not check them
out
use the address the thegreatcoursesplus.com/sixtysymbols to get started.
There's the link on the screen or you
can use the one I've put in the video description.
And a our thanks to the
great courses plus for supporting this video
[Plane noises]